okay last question yes are you all
drinking beyonce's piss yeah yeah no no
no no no you just said you already said
yes i thought you said my wife
see if you're if it's to be her girl his
her man or girl whatever she wants me to
do yeah you simpin you said yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i prefer chilled ice
rocks
glass sip
can you mix it with anything is it weird
i want to start drinking like a
chocolate
like i literally got a feeling i was
like we should have drink
twisty oranges on it and a straw you
want garnish you want that you're not
gonna go on raw we gotta go wrong you
can make it look nice
martini glass you gotta come on you
gotta use some clouds or i would do like
a um like a poland spring with a sport
top
do you like a sport top only if it's
beyonce's piss yo i heard urine can have
like um healing things
i said that to my wife when i pissed all
over my ass and she got a jellyfish bite
yeah it heals for jellyfishes yeah when
i dumped a hot piss on her ass
to save her